the New Hampshire primary is just around
the corner this is potentially a pivotal
moment in the Republican primary for
Nikki Haley New Hampshire could be her
best and last chance to persuade voters
that she's a better alternative to
Donald Trump here's
why the first primary of the 2024
election season is now a one-on-one
battle after Florida Governor Ronda
santis suspended his presidential bid
two days before the election and
endorsed former president Donald Trump I
can't ask our supporters to volunteer
their time and donate their resources if
we don't have a clear path to Victory
the New Hampshire primary comes off the
heels of the Republican caucuses in Iowa
where Trump won by a record-breaking
margin all but cementing his position as
the front runner for the party's
nomination we want to thank the great
people of Iowa thank you we love you all
but unlike Iowa New Hampshire has a more
moderate electorate and large numbers of
Independents are allowed to vote in the
state's GOP Primary New Hampshire is
much more independent-minded much more
secular this has always been a state
where the electorate was much more
friendly to the appeal of someone like
Nikki Haley who combines a sort of
conservative stance on taxes and
spending with conservative uh positions
on foreign policy and a pitch that's
about electability there's a substantial
block of democratic leaning Independents
who might like to take the nomination
away from Donald Trump there's a
substantial block of moderate
conservatives or conservative leaning
Independents all of these moderate
voters are a potential asset for a
candidate like Nikki
Haley with disantis out of the race
Haley has the opportunity to present
herself as the better and now only
alternative to trump it has been the
conventional wisdom that the only way
Trump could be beaten is if he were
one-on-one with a single alternative
giving voters that binary choice either
it's Trump or it's not do we want more
of the same
or do you want something different and
more of the same isn't just Joe Biden
more of the same is also Donald Trump
Haley believes she already has momentum
going into the New Hampshire primary she
has the endorsement of the very popular
Republican governor of New Hampshire
Chris cunu who's been very outspoken
against Trump and what he represents
Haley is also likely to scoop up some
supporters of former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie an avid Trump critic who
dropped out of the race just days before
the Iowa
caucuses however Trump remains dominant
in polls in New Hampshire and the states
to follow for future primaries with
DeSantis endorsing Trump after
suspending his campaign the support he
was drawing in New Hampshire will likely
go to Trump widening his lead another
decisive Victory could make the former
president nearly impossible to stop from
the perspective of the Trump campaign
this is already over you have a lot of
Trump's allies and campaign official
offals saying it's time to unite the
Republican Party Haley has tried to tow
this very delicate line of on the one
hand articulating what she believes are
valid criticisms of trump while not
angering the voters who still think that
Trump was a good president uh and like
him in a lot of ways and so for her it's
really New Hampshire that's due or die
she needs to either win or show that she
can come close to Donald Trump to give
her a reason to keep going forward it's
still early in the 2024 presidential
campaign season with many more State
primaries and caucuses to go ahead of
November's election but New Hampshire
will likely set the tone for another
major upcoming test the South Carolina
primary Trump looks very strong
throughout the South including in South
Carolina we've seen him get huge
reception when he's gone down there to
campaign so although it is Nikki Haley's
home state where she was a popular
Governor it's viewed as an uphill battle
for all the non-trump candidates if
Haley is able to come close or defeat
Trump in New sure she really looks like
U much more of a force in this campaign
and it starts to look like a real
contest now she still has an uphill
battle in South Carolina but at least it
looks like an actual
battle